el primer contacto con el skate fue
cuando tenía más o menos de 7 años mi
padre me regaló un skate por navidad y
una base de datos para 15 años cuando
tenía casi 15 años unos compañeros de
clase que ya andaban en skate me
invitaron a la inauguración de una pista
aquel día aprendí a tirarme de la rampa
y la sensación que tuve la sensación de
haber conseguido hacer algo que parecía
muy difícil una sensación de superación
eso me llevó a desear sentir aquello
todos los días de mi vida cuando comencé
a practicar el skate estaba acabando el
instituto conseguía entrar en la
universidad federal y comencé a
frecuentar las clases pero al mismo
tiempo estaba evolucionando en el skate
amando cada vez más este deporte y
deseando pasar más tiempo encima de este
carrito pasaba este impresionante cambio
sé que mi corazón era lo que me hacía
feliz ahora defenestrado
[Música]
este es mi padre que tal papá cómo estás
este es mi profesor de yoga bruno ni
siquiera esté aquí es mi paraíso mi
pista que acabamos de terminar es que lo
que para el skate el hecho de estar en
unos juegos olímpicos trae un cierto
respeto en las oportunidades el apoyo y
los incentivos que no teníamos muchas
veces el skate era considerado algo
marginal
más marginalizados
ahora vamos a hacer unos ejercicios de
respiración un poco de meditación
[Música]
yo uso el yoga como una válvula de
escape principalmente para calmar mi
mente en el día a día durante la semana
desde aquí dibuje la pista de tokio en
la que vamos a competir en los juegos
olímpicos para poder soñar y pensar lo
que voy a hacer allá aquí en mi cuarto
imagino las líneas y las maniobras el
mero hecho de ser los primeros skaters
de la historia que participan en unos
juegos olímpicos ya es algo muy especial
literalmente histórico entonces me
siento muy feliz y honrada por formar
parte de esta historia seremos para
siempre los primeros skaters que
participan en unos juegos olímpicos